on se sent assez seul ici
[Musique]
Je mène à retrouver les souvenirs que les
Cris ont pris pour moi
tu es Carol Danvers la personne la plus puissante que
j'ai connue bien avant que tu puisses tirer du
feu avec tes poings
J'ai des ennuis pour ça je dois voir
ça à propos de toi
mais que se passera-t-il quand
je serai enfin libéré
Je serai de retour avant que tu t'en rendes compte Les
ennuis du lieutenant
quand tu es parti,
maman est décédée
et j'ai été renvoyé,
ils nous ont arrondis pour enquêter sur
les anomalies liées à la Terre Monica non,
comment tu te sens moi-même
maintenant  Je peux manipuler les longueurs d'onde du
spectre électromagnétique Je suis très heureux
pour toi, où est notre fille, oui, où
est-elle,
oh mon Dieu,
comment fais-tu pour que
ma grand-mère me l'ait envoyé par courrier, as-
tu déjà voulu quelque chose d'aussi mauvais
et c'est en fait  C'est arrivé
mais ce n'est pas aussi génial que tu l'imaginais
tu veux sauver le monde
Alors tu vas sauver le monde
[Musique]
mais dis-moi ce qui
se passe, nous changeons de place
chaque fois que nous utilisons nos pouvoirs
plus élevés, plus rapidement
ensemble